what I'd like to know from all of you is
what was that first scene and that's in
the script when you first read it and
you thought I have to do this part
anyone well I hadn't really acted before
and was really young so it wasn't like I
need to do this for although it was kind
of just more of a hobby at the beginning
but yeah I think she's kind of similar
to me but yeah that my 12 year old head
didn't realize that it was going to turn
out for me the audition scene for
Margaery Tyrell was the famous scene
where she offers Renly Baratheon to use
Loras in the room with her her own
brother whatever will get him going I
had watched season one watched Mazie
season one and Game of Thrones and I
thought Thrones just wrote really three
dimensional complex women really well
there was equality there which was
wonderful so I just wanted to be a part
of the show so Natalie I love that
you've described Marjorie is this woman
who uses with the modern PR angle that's
got like the princess die Michelle Obama
hearts and minds thing down and I just
wonder how manipulative is she I mean is
it all about playing the angles or is
there like there's some deep heart in
there too what's her motivation um
what type of vision is fantastic in his
way ahead of film is it doesn't feel the
need polarize women so much I
experienced it in plane and Berlin as
well that male writers and I say this
with all love and respect often want to
make a woman either the angel or the
[ __ ] the whip there you know make her
the witch or put her on the pedestal and
when people ask me about Marjorie I say
you don't they're not mutually exclusive
you don't have to be practical and
politically savvy and not be
good person you can be a good human
being and be and just be shrewd I think
all these women play similar characters
they're not two separate things that
were part of the people in this room are
probably female we are as complex where
is complex and contradictory as the men
and Marjorie is a character that
reflects that yeah definitely
now amazing your character has had a
rough couple years and wandering all
those hillsides and not so good out
there and I just thought last scene that
you had with the Hound where you walked
away it was just it was pretty
incredible and it seems like a big
transformative moment for your character
and I wondered how that was for you to
play that how you saw it it was the main
change in Aria so far I feel like every
year we're never sure if we're going to
come back for another season and you
want a nice closure for your character
and I feel like heading into the new
season it's like we've just finished
that chapter of Arya's life that's who
she was then and she let go of
everything that she kind of had before
and I mean doing that scene I knew it
was coming for a long time and the way
that it was done in the series it's very
different to the way it was done in the
books
and I'd wanted to know how people would
react to that it seems to go down pretty
well it was it was a hard thing to do it
was hard to say goodbye to Rory we'd
spent so much time together this year
and he's such a great guy and yeah the
scene the when I read it on paper and
when I came to set it kind of just
seemed to go really seamlessly and um we
all sort of had the same idea of how the
scene was gonna go in our head and when
we got there and it sort of played out
the way it did it just felt really
natural which is great because sometimes
you have to change a lot of things to
please different people on set so it was
nice that we all had the same idea for
it you guys have had to do a lot of
physical things and all your roles and
master different weapons guns carving
forks and swords and supernatural powers
and things like that are there any
that have been particularly challenging
or particularly fun to do or things you
really enjoy it as far as the training
goes perhaps the sword play things like
so in the books Aria was written as a
left-handed fighter and I am
right-handed and when I started the
production I decided that I wanted to do
everything left-handed and stayed true
to the books which started out as a
vapor giggle and it's good fun and now
it's turning out to be kind of difficult
well I'm sticking with it and yeah I
mean it worked out fine
and a lot of the time I come in to learn
a stunt sequence and it's been
choreographed right-handed because they
forget and then I have to come in and
say actually we got to change it all
because I'm gonna use my other hand
which is a bit of a nightmare but
exciting and outs another twist of it I
guess I've been having a lot of fun
running around on the Hunger Games with
a semi-automatic rifle and I was I was
so ready to get rid of the silk skirt in
the corsets and but now after nine
months of mud and dirt and yeah be
really physical I'm ready to go back to
the silk skirt so Maisie
you know the first thing Emma Watson did
after she finished playing Hermione was
she cut off all her hair she was so sick
of like being a teenager and not being
able to express herself the way she
wanted to because she was for my knee
and I just wonder if that's something
you relate to being Arya Stark during
your teenage years and yeah totally I
mean this industry we have to be blank
canvases and I've realized that and then
when you get a role they build on that
and and you become that person and
particularly being so young in this
industry I feel like I have to find who
I am as a person like anyway and go
through my teenage years and also live
in the limelight and you know juggle all
of that at once which sometimes does get
really really hectic and yeah it's it's
hard I would love to
you know do crazy things with my hair
and I recently got my nose pierced and
that was like all hell breaking loose
and everyone was like uh it doesn't have
a nose piercing this is crazy
yeah so it's difficult and you know it's
to try and express yourself and and and
be yourself which is what everyone
caught disgusts me telling me you know
just be yourself and be true to yourself
and it's kind of hard to do that when
you can't because yeah for whatever
reason yeah it's just finding the
balance between the two I guess we're
kind of on the flip side now only what
we were talking about earlier is
sometimes these roles allow you to do
things that maybe you wouldn't be brave
enough to do on your own like maybe you
wouldn't shave one side of your head if
it was up to you but for the part it was
something that you were required to do
and then you kind of get to like own it
it's something that makes it's probably
really fun and I would guess yeah the
beauty of being an actor is that you
find yourself in places physically in
places or doing things or learning
things that you wouldn't ordinarily do
and so we have a multitude of lives for
the price of one hmm and you know that
is the that's the gift of being an actor
so and Tatiana like times that like my
times over say yeah so if you guys could
trade roles any of your cast mates on
your current shows Tatiana is kind of a
hard question for you to answer but for
everyone else who would you want to play
to to play somebody else on your shows
that you're currently on so see longest
dead Cersei Lannister you're just
talking about this backstage because
apparently there is a quiz online which
Game of Thrones character are you have
you guys Dez anyone done this
so you can go online and you answer some
basic multi choice questions and what
character are you and I did it good as
Natalie Dormer and I was area star cool
and I've never done it but 1/2 T now I'm
fingers crossed I get sesang nice he's
gonna be a Peter Dinklage I think she's
gonna be Terry so being a woman that
kicks ass you guys have the right to get
mad and be pissed off
is there anything well what pisses you
off about Hollywood right now it's
really interesting because you said
earlier and then Nicole is also
commented on how liberating it is to not
worry to do a job where you're not
worried about how you look mm-hmm and
because the the focus seems to be on
that for women and it's not there in you
guys because you're watching us and you
don't realize how much makeup and how
much lighting is involved when we look
good we've got a lot of help going on
you know you don't look good that's just
what we look like yeah I often think
that it's not healthy for young girls to
be flicking through these magazines and
to be looking at films and TV and seeing
these shows like I feel quite strongly
about it because you know there's a more
European attitude if you look at French
film or Spanish film that they're a
little bit more open to the quirks of
human nature that we're not all
symmetrical that we're not all one shape
you know that people are oddballs in
different ways aesthetically
cosmetically as well as emotionally in
personality and you need more of that
films features the best female roles I
think are in television at the moment I
really do and other and Katniss Everdeen
is as popular as she is because she's an
anomaly she really is like that so
that's my point
I do live-action role play which
requires me to know a lot about combat
and I was curious what the most unique
element has been for you guys to learn a
stunt whose job
for what el I've actually told ya he's
gonna come back and shoot gonna tell us
um live-action roleplay is interactive
theatre a book a video game that has
been turned into a live-action event
where you get to be those characters Oh
any tips for your action stunts that you
guys have done you go Natalie you've
done them haven't you talk about that
machine gun yeah I mean actually doing
it um I I I get to hold the sword as
Margaery Tyrell but I went to drama
school with Nicole's co-star Tom Mison
we trained together and at drama school
in Britain you do a lot of you do a lot
of stage fighting stage combat it's like
part of our fantastical thing and
because we're so superior and Tom and I
used to do workshops at the Globe
Theatre there is like the Shakespeare
Theatre where obviously in a lot of
Shakespeare plays there's a lot of
combat sword fights and just I always
couldn't get your I didn't like the
authenticity never it never felt right
so for a couple of years I went and took
up fencing and actually doing it for
real like shooting a gun for real is the
best way to there and actually I
referenced her already but that Jennifer
Lawrence when she shoots a bow and arrow
in La Hunger Games nine times out of ten
she doesn't really have the arrow
it's CGI put in probably gonna get in
really big trouble um I don't think it
was the case in the first film but I
think for practical reasons they found
it better to add it in afterwards but
she shoots arrows the real thing for
training constantly
constantly so that them so that the
action is a hundred percent authentic
when the arrow actually is no longer
there so does that make sense yes might
it very hot hi I'm Katherine my
questions for the whole panel I was
wondering if you could say your favorite
kick-ass moment that your character one
of your characters has had not
necessarily physically kicking us but
personal triumphs or victory kick-ass
moment my character aria a lot of the
time is very confrontational and never
really very passive usually just comes
out and says what she feels except for
one time in season two it's the scene
between Aria and Tywin Lannister
when Arya tells Tywin that any one can't
be killed and at the time he doesn't
realize who she is and kind of doesn't
think anything of it but she knows at
the back of her head what that really
means to her and what that really means
when she says out loud and what that's
gonna mean to him in the future my
kick-ass moment would be I want to be
the queen
I was wondering if any of your cast
members on your respective shows have
ever had a scene that maybe you wish
that you could have performed yourself
and/or if if you could pick one what
would it be
I'd love to just do more stunts a lot of
the time we have doubles that do things
for us in case we get injured or
whatever which is in my opinion so yeah
I'd love to do more of my own stuff and
I'd love to do more work with the horses
I know Richard Madden who plays Robb
Stark got to actually gallop and like I
want to actually go up instead of
someone else going for me so yeah I'd
love to do more stuff with the horses
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh god I think I just want to be used to
all the ladies out there if you had the
opportunity to play any super hero or
villain regardless of gender who would
it be
I would pay Spider Man because because
the typical superhero look is this
strong muscly big character and I like
the Spider Man is kind of patch Isle and
not that and like kind of unsuspecting
as well rather than like coming out and
like lifting up the car it's like I
don't know I feel like it's a lot more
subtle than that yeah it's fine man
I was always a huge Batman fan like the
the psychology of that man is so
interesting and it's why it had so many
reincarnations I always yeah Batman hi
I'm Jess my question is from a Xion
Natalie busy your characters scene is a
very fiery character and Natalie your
character is seen as a very resourceful
character and I suppose my question is
which one do you think is more ruthless
in the series the way Marjorie can
manipulate characters is not something
to be messed with
at all so it's for very different
reasons I mean physically brutal you
know some of the kill scenes that Aria
has had have been vile for a 12 year old
to be experienced in that firsthand
it's awful and I think we would like to
turn a blind eye to that actually as
well which is something that I kind of
wanted to bring up that there's a 12
year old girl that is she living in this
world and we all like to kind of brush
that aside that she actually just put a
sword through someone's throat and like
hey that's such a kick-ass moment which
it is but that's you can't live your
life like that and be okay in the head
forever like that's not the way it works
so then coming on to so 10 so then
coming on to episode 10 when Aria just
decided to leave the Hound there is no
real reason as to why she's not sure
what's right and what's wrong anymore
and there is really no right or wrong
answer because that's what Game of
Thrones is is just these people that are
desperately trying to
for whatever reason gain power or the
throne or revenge on that family or you
know and I think it's difficult to say
that a character is good oh my it is
totally not the nail on the head by say
and you have it's an astute question
because the answer is Game of Thrones
shows you all the different ways you can
wield power whether it's psychological
physical sexual dragons I think we don't
get the dragons if we were given a
choice you know that's the secret of the
writing that's why it's such a
compelling show because it shows how
different people are given different
weapons physically and metaphorically
and how they use them
you